from the day after tomorrow and House of
Flying Daggers please welcome Jake
Gyllenhaal and Vivi yang
miracles are still be made in motion
pictures if there's something impossible
to be done in a movie the producer turns
to a team of visual effects people and
here are this year's visual effects
wizards
for Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban
Roger Guyot Tim Burke John Richardson
for iRobot John Nelson Andrew R Jones
Eric Nash and Joel Atari
for spider-man to John Dykstra Scott
stock Dyke Antle Imola Nara and John
Frazier
and the Oscar goes to John Dykstra go
fight and the millionaire for spider-man
to John Frazier
this is the first Academy Award for
Scott stock by Anthony la manera and
John Fraser John Dykstra takes home his
second Oscar
I love my job what an honor to be
singled out in a year with so much
terrific work boy am i glad there wasn't
a fourth episode of Lord of the Rings
what a joy to work and share this award
with so many talented people
our director Sam Raimi Scott Anthony
John all of the artists technicians and
producers had collaborated on the
effects for this picture we'd like to
thank our families high-caste chloe mom
we'd like to thank Sony Pictures for all
your support Thank You Academy thank you
everyone
ladies and gentlemen welcome the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences mr. Frank
Pierson
on this Oscar Sunday and this Tabernacle
of talent my sermon is going to be brief
we dedicate the 77th academy award
services to our men and women in the
armed services wherever they serve with
our gratitude forever for the sacrifices
that they have made in serving our
country
we want you all to know that we are not
forget we have not forgotten you and we
hope that wherever you are if you have
the time to see a movie that our film
brings you back home again for an hour
or so and our prayers for your swift and
safe return
thirty years ago a brilliant young
director cast a brilliant young actor to
play the lead in my screenplay for Dog
Day Afternoon and my gratitude and
admiration for the actor and for that
director has remained absolutely
unabated please join me in welcoming
that oscar-winning actor Al Pacino thank
you
thank you